well I'm joined now by the former
England and Liverpool player a legend
John Barnes very good to talk to you
John so hey and honor for me a step
closer they're training contact training
again the players that the safety
systems are in place extensive testing
is happening do you think it is actually
going to happen June the 19th being
penciled in well I don't know whether
June of 91 to happen but just for the
very fact that they are now trailing and
of course it was for a socially
distancing now there's gonna be contact
so of course the next step would be to
get back into inter matches but that's
the weather that date is going to be
June the 19th we don't really know but
it's glad to see that they're moving in
the right direction and getting back
into yeah have you been talking to any
of the players do you know do they still
have concerns there were some players
not from Liverpool that I noticed though
that said well you know I'm still
concerned about perhaps taking it home
to my family do you think that
particularly their the extensive testing
has a laid those fears well of course
Troy Dean is probably the high-profile
one who said he has concerns because
he's got a young child but of course
individuals may have those concerns not
just in football but when time comes for
everybody to go back to work be you a
milkman whenever it is then and he's
decided that your industries gonna go
back there will be individuals who may
decide that they aren't prepared to do
that and football is no different so no
choice one and there one or two others
as to whether they start to play again
we don't know but what has to happen is
that the authorities along with the
guidance of the of the experts and the
government have have to make a decision
as to when they're going to go back then
if individuals choose not to
you have to respect their wishes as well
okay and they're as fans we of course
both hope it does happen what about this
issue of atmosphere there I'm sure you
like may have been watching the
Bundesliga the German top league and my
goodness me they do feel like training
games without a crowd there what it's
not perfect but these are you know these
are times which we've never seen before
and of course if you want perfection in
terms of full stadiums you may have to
wait six months a year we don't really
know but if you want to get back to
playing as quickly as as and as safely
as possible you're gonna have to go
through this the situation whereby
you're gonna have to play
in front of empty stadiums without then
complaining that there's no atmosphere
you can't have it both ways
if you want to get back early and safely
we'll have to go back with empty
stadiums and hope that as time goes on
we'd be able to reassess the situation
later on and it'd be nice for Liverpool
wounded I mean you know the way they
have won and it is won the Premier
League it has to be confirmed by a few
more points but the way they've played
this season Annie personally you would
feel it rather cheated maybe even is
that too strong a way to say if the
season was not finished and the
Liverpool were not officially crowned
well it's not just about Liverpool
you've got Leeds who want to come from
from the championship and a West Brom or
Fulham and teach are going to be
relegated as well I think the integrity
of the sport and integrity of
competition the winner should win the
bottom three should go down the top
three in the league's below should come
up so yes it'd be great for Liverpool
but I just think more in terms of the
integrity of competition we have to add
thereto to the normal season in terms of
trying to play out the season I know
victory parade oh of course if it does
happen what though about this issue and
again it's coming from Germany without
that crowd there the sense that there
isn't really any home advantage well the
home advantage doesn't just come from
the fact that you're playing in front of
40,000 of your own fans it's the drive
to the stadium it's the dressing rooms
is a familiarity around the ground in
the players lounge you know just a
routine to go through which you go
through every other week in home rather
than the away team who comes here once a
year so yes home advantage is about the
crowd but it's also about the
familiarity about your surroundings
which there will be a small advantage
that the home teams do have and what
about fitness I mean so they've had a
long layoff we know they all stay fit
but it's not the same I'm told obviously
you know I don't that's actually playing
week in week out so they're trying to
get match fit again and then we have the
potential at this point the Premier
League finishing those that are in the
European competitions where we haven't
heard from you way for yet perhaps
playing those as well even the FA Cup we
haven't actually heard about that then
this next season which again we haven't
heard about a delay there middle of
August back into a new season on into
the euros I mean you know they can't
that means something's got to give has
it not well first of all
they're not really on fit because of
course modern players stay fit the whole
year round secondly if they start this
season once again they'll play nine to
ten games which means come the end of
the season which is only nine to ten
games they won't be tired because
they've already played 10 games so I
don't see why they count straight go
back into the next season or the urals
having only played 10 games so they're
not going to be tired they won't need a
rest as if it's the end of the season so
you need two months off they could play
the 9 to 10 games to finish the season
obviously one or two weeks to whoever's
been promoted has been relegated players
contracts and then go straight into the
next season rather than you know saying
it's the end of the season we have to
have two months off before next season
you just continue played there's only be
nine games gone John I sorry we've got
to stop just being told could talk to
you all night thank you very much indeed
John Barnes there now legend